there is infinitely more power in ESG
businesses like Disney than in say like
the daily wire now you're speaking my
language but this is the challenge
how do you compete like the daily wires
got to make money Disney doesn't yeah
facts and the reason they don't is
because of their relationship to the
government and and the world economic
forum and all of the the oh go ahead
it's you're mostly right I was just
going to say also that
they own so much IP true that the
average person will just pay the 10
bucks because they're like I can watch
Flubber yeah well and I think that
the audience is not going to like this
but at the end of the day we do need to
as consumers of this media the people
that want to see something different in
the world that isn't you know perverted
and messing up our children you need to
you need to put your money where your
mouth is you can't just continue to
consume free content this is why you
know we have to diversify we're on
rumbles of course Liberty
lockdown.locals.com as well for people
that want to support the show so that I
can actually tell the truth if I can get
enough people that are doing that then I
don't have to worry about de-platforming
and things like that but the ESG factor
in this is such a big deal and and I it
drives me crazy because ultimately it's
becoming a partisan issue where you have
red State Governors are really really
engaging in this and God bless them we
need it but at the same time I wish it
weren't partisan in nature I wish we
understood that that having a a
monolithic globalist perspective on how
to utilize and manipulate Capital
markets to try and reimagine the world
in your image well you're not always
going to be in church charge just the
same same concept of like do you want
Donald Trump to have these Powers no you
don't well then maybe it's not okay when
Biden does it same same concept with ESG
yes right now it is being utilized to to
uh propagate a very
neoliberal World Order well what if that
what if that Dynamic changes because it
inevitably will maybe it'll be a hundred
years but it's going to change at some
point do we want big business to be
reimagining our civilization like the
answer to me is clearly no particularly
when it's nameless faceless Bankers that
are primarily uh responsible for this
stuff or if they are known they're
they're at Davos with 500 security
guards and hookers five thousand was it
five thousand soldiers oh my God that
were given police power or coercion if
you need 5 000 soldiers to protect
yourself you're doing something wrong
you're doing something wrong and and
like I'm not I I don't I'm not at all
wanting them to be threatened or injured
at all but there's a reason that people
are so concerned about your
you're trying to manipulate and coerce
the entire world we're talking eight
billion people that you want all to live
in this particular worldview where
carbon emissions are such a danger where
the thing that I exhale makes me a
danger to every man woman and child on
Earth it's a very anti-human perspective
and ultimate ultimately it's
anti-capitalist this is one other
talking point that I have to get across
is that this is not capitalism that
we're dealing with and when people talk
about it as if it is it drives me
absolutely insane this is a fascistic
model correct crystal clear fascistic
model and you can't then hold that up
and say look at all of these evil things
that are happening in our world this is
why we have to go towards socialism
we're basically down that path already
you know the big challenges these ESG
companies
ESG is the require is is the
prerequisite for financial investment
yes so in West Virginia these fossil
fuel companies call or whatever are like
hey you know we need a loan of five
million dollars to expand our operation
hire more employees and they go no
and then someone comes out and says we
want a drag queen story and they're like
oh how much do you need for that and you
know where that money comes from
Federal Reserve how do you compete with
an industry that can print infinite
money for itself
doesn't that make this whole it just
makes it hard it's harder and that means
we need all of these companies that are
in the independent and
anti-establishment space to be operating
on the exact same capacity don't hire
woke people right hire people believe in
Freedom yeah Empower people who believe
in Freedom so this is the point and if
you're a consumer of that media support
people that are providing that that
media you really have to like you have
to if you want to see that you have to
actually contribute so this is you know
basically everything that we do here and
why we do it why do we hire people we
hire because their job is to be a
positive influence on the world and
that's more important than the revenue
we're we're uh an ideological company in
a sense
Tim cast makes money yeah the other
shows make money but Tim cast makes the
overall majority of it and then that
money is the resource that we use to
have people make cool and good and
positive things
I love it we need a hell of a lot more
of it I was just I was just going to
comment on like how absurd it is when
you really think about
um like this whole thing is over fake
money and uh the message that it's that
it the division that it'll cause in the
conservative movement which I'm not a
conservative so whatever but it's just
interesting to see them kind of squabble
over this and it's all just fake money
in the end of the day yeah the federal
reserve prints it out of thin air it's
going to be worthless anyway soon and
he's so crowded yeah you don't need to
worry about this don't worry it's all
going to be devalued at the end of the
day what are you gonna have your
experiences your own company what you
built yourself don't let anyone else
build anything for you but this is again
my strategy people are built different
this is just who I am after being
through a lot of rough crazy situations
in my life dealing with other businesses
um who knows maybe he'll strive more and
be better under a contract but for me
personally there's a road to take I'm
taking that road I just think it's so
important that we encourage people that
that share our value system and have the
drive that we do in this room to
actually follow that passion and follow
that path because there's just been such
a dearth of entrepreneurial spirit and I
get it I get it you are it's so stacked
against you especially if you're like a
young college graduate and you're coming
out and you're like you understand ESG
which obviously makes you a very rare 23
year old or whatever but say you do
understand it you know what an uphill
slog that's gonna be like you're gonna
try and compete head to head with the
biggest businesses that have ever
existed in human history and at the end
of the day they have a you know a
sweetheart deal with all of the biggest
governments on earth oh on top of that
they have a sweetheart deal with the
central banks of the world where they
can just buy Fiat create debt and credit
like I get it but it doesn't matter we
have to compete we have to try if we
just acquiesce and we we were talking
about the black people earlier right
that's true yeah if we give up it's over
right we can't give up right we have to
try one thing you mentioned earlier Tim
is that uh wondering like is everyone
cut out to run a company or a business
or something like that along those lines
the answer is no no they're not and
there's a difference that's important to
keep in mind between a business and a
company a company is a type of business
that involves two or more people which
is why it has come penny with patreon
you know with people company and it's a
companion you know uh business you can
be have a business as a sole proprietor
as soon as you start hiring people or
bringing other people on you become a
company and at that point do you want to
run a company do you want to be involved
with other people's day-to-day activity
do you want to be taking meetings do you
want to be intricately you know
responsible for these people's behavior
that's the question and that's that's
also that's like a it's like an art form
we've been offered deals by
all the big players in the space and all
the deals were bad
and I'm just like
man
I don't know what these companies are
doing we could write a Cool Tech deal
not that we we don't do Tech at timcast
but we could the the tech are you
talking about is this like like an nft
contract is you know explain that uh I
would do like uh uh we would set up
hosting or navigate to some sort of
Hosting like on Rumble build like a
front end and up make sure that it's if
there's bugs that we have developers
that are fixing the bugs on the Fly 24 7
and
um so we would technically help you host
your own content and provide your
subscribers a direct Revenue to you and
then we could technically take money off
the top if we wanted to I'm building a
charity right now that's building this
software so ultimately it'll be free for
everyone to use and I'm not taking
anything for it all of these uh all
these companies calling me non-stop like
whenever there's drama you know what I
mean I I don't I don't I I there's
there's a lot that I won't talk about
because I don't think it changes the
political the the political landscape
you know if it did I would come out just
be like sorry guys you know but there's
there's private stuff and I always try
to avoid
things that I think might hurt as it's
standard journalistic ethic it's
minimize harm
you uh I've I've talked with the blaze
for years
uh said no every time uh I've talked
with the daily wire I've talked with
Rumble you know there's a couple other
companies that we we've negotiated with
and some we've done deals with and I
just say no to all of them and I think
one of the things these companies don't
get is where we are in the modern
landscape I think they're hoping
I think I think they're hoping that
someone like me is a guy who's like just
wants to sit in the room and go on
camera and then go play ball with it
with his kid or you know Future kid or
something like that or dog or whatever
that's what they're trying to sell you
on
yeah and and they do they they all say
the same thing like you shouldn't be
worrying about this stuff man exactly
you know like let us take care of the
heavy lifting and I'm just like
you know what's gonna happen
I'll tell you what's gonna happen I say
this to every single person I've ever
talked to in any company
and I learned my lesson with Fusion but
I got paid and I used that money to
invest and build this I'm like we're
going to start we're going to be excited
we're gonna get the ball rolling six
months in I'm gonna come to you and say
problem X is solved by Y and you're
going to say okay well I don't have time
to deal with this some will take care of
it and I say no it's a problem in my
life that needs to be solved now for the
show and if I don't have the authority
to do it then I'm going to be in a very
bad mood and then you're not going to be
able to so there's no point in doing
these contracts that and
yeah I just I I think these these
companies they're archaic they can sit
down and explain to you exactly why like
I mentioned like why they do the penalty
deal with Crowder's contract and then
Crowder's appropriate responses that's
insane it wasn't insane 20 years ago it
wasn't insane 30 years ago but it is now
when Crowder is the captain of the ship
and he should be the one running it and
they should be working for him let me
add one thing uh because I I probably
black pulled a lot of people but
demonstrating how challenging it is
going to be to compete and succeed in
this space however because of the the
monopolistic power or at least
oligopolistic power that these operators
have
they don't face a lot of real
competition so when they when there is
genuine competition and and also they're
very bureaucratic they're very slow
moving they become very comfortable
overly confident that is all areas of of
opportunity for for entrepreneurs to try
and rise up there's enormous market
demand for honest dialogue your success
has been very clearly proof of that so
there is market demand but there is also
captured markets that make it very
challenging to enter and compete in that
space but it doesn't mean that we can't
create competing Avenues and platforms I
don't I pray to God that Rumble because
it does seem to be like they're they're
the real deal so far
um I pray to God that them locals these
competition actually rise up and they
create an opportunity for that for that
market demand to be met because there is
a demand an entrepreneur should realize
that I've had private conversations with
several big YouTube channels many of
these uh big channels have contacted me
and said look these contracts are really
bad what do we do we should form a
network blah blah blah and I say no
every time what you're asking is
impossible the network model won't work
so here's an idea that's been floated
around by a bunch of people you know and
love behind the scenes so I'll leave
nameless because it's their business but
I'll tell you about what my experience
I get phone calls we do group calls and
they're like we need to compete we need
to change the game how can we do it
let's create a network
let's create a single destination for
all these big creators and then we'll
figure out a way to split the revenue
and I say okay how do you split the
revenue
um we can do it by when someone signs up
they can write down the name of someone
what if they write on nothing what if
they sign up as a general member where's
that money go well we split it evenly is
that fair what if I'm getting 60 million
per month and you're getting 500 000 I'm
giving you half the money that comes in
sure it's not fair to me why would I do
that what if you're getting 100 million
and I'm getting 50 million I get half
your money that makes sense I'm making a
third of of the revenue
so I've had these conversations over and
over again because everybody wants to
coalesce and use this network the idea
is there is an individual out there
who's like man I love Tim guest and then
he goes man I love Crowder I'm not going
to spend 10 bucks for either of them
wait a minute they're bundled together
and 10 bucks gets me both now I'll do it
sure that's what these people think will
happen but what ends up happening is
someone like Crowder with six six
million followers will get half a
million people to watch on Election
night he'll get 50 000 people to sign up
instantly and then good luck sorting who
signed up for who and how much everyone
deserves you might be able to set it up
so you have to toggle who you're signing
up for in order to sign up or everyone
has their own unique links and websites
but it goes to the same centralized
thing so uh Crowder has Mud Club you
have yeah yeah so but they all go to the
same place and they all get everything
in a bundle well so that means I'm
giving my content away for free and
someone's giving 10 bucks you give a
small percentage right how do you
determine the percentage
um you could do it by viewership who
gets uh the percentage of viewership
it's going to be complicated it's not
I'm not saying I have the solution well
I'm just I'm just spitballing it's
impossible I don't know because if I was
signing up say it's you and Steve
Crowder are splitting it I sign up and I
pick I have to pick you or Steve in
order to sign up so you have that data
and then if there's a smart contract
behind the scenes where the this is
futuristic but if the money is split
automatically
72 percent to you 28 to Stephen based on
the subscriber data I would that might
work
you know what'll happen
let's say Bob jimin and Jill do this
deal Bob's got a million Jim's got five
hundred thousand Jill's got five million
you know she's a very attractive you
know podcaster everybody wants to follow
her and then uh the money comes in and
then you've got this big jumbled mess of
numbers
763 896 the first week 430 896 the
second week you got 13 signed up for
Jill seven percent said Bob you know 12
said you know Jim or whatever name I
don't remember the name I used and then
one day someone goes in and says hold on
man I only got paid 300 000 this month I
normally we do 500 what happened well
let's look at the numbers no no that
can't be right how are you getting more
money than me this is everybody fights
everybody else
it's not gonna work it does sound like
an optimal situation for a smart
contract system to be developed where
you could automate the payments based on
the math behind the scenes everything's
on a blockchain or open source so if you
have questions you just take it up with
the math that'd have to be a really
smart
contracts the question is timcast.com is
wholly independent with no investors
with uh no no outside financing just
customers and and advertisers yeah the
advertisers are almost entirely
programmatic meaning we have very very
few direct sponsors I think we have like
eight or ten it changes with the podcast
audio version obviously you guys know we
do virtual Shield bio trust like that's
basically the only two sponsors we have
them periodically do pepper speak stuff
and then uh for the podcast version we
have a handful it's like you know Bambi
and like you know things like that
Hartford gold there's like five or six
and that uh so almost all of it's
programmatic
why would I
create any kind of mud in this company's
Revenue stream by doing a partnership
deal in the hopes that I can increase
Revenue by by a certain percentage by
teaming up with someone like Stephen
Crowder I think you'd only be able to
bring in someone of comparable
clout I hate to use that term but you
know someone that's lesser over
interesting why some would have
comparable clout I mean we're looking at
two people who have comparable amounts
of Revenue who are now going to argue
about the gains and which direction it
goes that's true but I mean there is
there is strength in in networking I
just think you're right though that
obviously a formal Network creates
infighting and jealousy and competition
especially if you have two Alphas that
are like on the on the rise anyways
this this system only makes sense to the
businessman whose sole job is to
maintain it
for for Stephen Crowder and for me there
is zero reason for either of us to do a
network deal because at the end of the
day Steven can pick up his phone and
talk to his phone with no crew with no
employees and he makes money
same thing for me because we are the
people creating the content right so the
people you'll heal at you'll hear advert
advocate for these deals are the people
who do nothing but these deals that's it
yeah they're like if I can bring all
these guys together
I'm gonna make money off the top well
you could do you and Steven together 14
bucks a month so already you're making
seven instead of ten you're gonna take a
hit but then the idea would be you'd get
more like 40 of a of a 10 000 multiple
is better than a hundred percent of a
one times multiple you can't predict it
this is unpredictable that's true a
cultural issue where people are they
want what's uh expedient and not not
what's meaningful so like you know if
you get if you get deleted off of
Twitter you don't exist to me and that's
just the way it is yeah I've seen it a
thousand times and I think you know it's
good that this discussion is out there
right now because people need to start
to like open up their mind to what's
actually going on here like you said we
need to support these creators if it's
ten dollars a month I like Crowder if
it's ten dollars a month I like Tim cast
let's do both I'm not going to spend ten
dollars elsewhere this needs to be out
there more the devastating part about it
is like even though I have a pretty uh
passionate fan base
I get nuked from YouTube for a couple
weeks I I start a rumble Channel up you
still see like even though I have one
tenth the subscribership over on Rumble
my viewership is only cut in half so
like a lot of my people are still
rocking with me even though you know
it's a subscriber limit is is way
reduced
um but it's just it's interesting how
how platform captured people are to make
a uh I have two podcasts two YouTube
channels yes I do I do too I have two
YouTube channels one of them I stopped
using in 2008 it was called cross Mac
and I was like I don't like that people
are calling me cross smack to my face I
want to be branded Ian Crossland so I
made a new Channel people still comment
on Cross Mac that I like oh my God you
still make videos like I'll make a new
video every once while on Cross Mech
they they're not only are they siled on
a platform they're siled on channels yes
yes yes yes yes so we could break that
with a multi-network system too that
would be great you want to know the
worst thing in the world is is YouTube
is like one of the worst platforms uh
let me let me let me do some math real
quick I think on
Apple Spotify and the audio platforms
you will make let me let me let me do
some quick math here or what do we get
um
I think you'll make like five times as
much money off ads
or maybe maybe it's way more than that
oh it's big are you saying versus uh
video oh dude it's huge like for
whatever reason YouTube ad revenue is
gutter trash yes if you can get
25 25 per thousand CPM is kind of
standard on audio like that's 300 300
000 views downloads on a podcast on a
Daily Show you're going to be making
holy crap you're talking 10 7 500. 7 500
per ad
yep it declines as the as the as the ad
goes on but uh you got to be making like
10 million per year if you're if you're
at those numbers easy easy and this is
one on YouTube if you're getting 300 000
you're getting 300 000 views I'll get
you a thousand bucks yeah so you'll make
300 000 per year on YouTube with the
same amount of traffic but they're
depending on your channel too because
like my channel compared to other
channels is getting 30 times less than
what channels are supposed to be getting
what you're saying the three ten to to
to you know sometimes 30. wow yeah but I
confirmed 10. well I think that might be
an Ethics violation is just a special
thing like we should not be playing
favorites about it who gets more money
that's like a social justice crap well
YouTube justifies it by saying this
channel is a little bit too spicy and
not Advertiser friendly this channel is
advertising that's how they kind of
justify I counter that is let the
adverts speak to themselves exactly
even though there's not a big difference
between the two content YouTube still
deems like hey this is not good this is
good this is what we like after we just
got done badmouthing networks and saying
how unfeasible all of this is for the
past hour and a half I gotta say that
our boys Dave Smith and Louis J Gomez uh
gas digital they have signed Tower gang
to gas digital I just wanted to shout
out Lewis you're like a brother to me
thank you so much for bringing us on
board your con your contract looks a
little bit like that and I'd like you to
work on it but other than that we
appreciate you uh putting your love and
faith tell me about gas digital real
quick gas digital is basically a largely
a comedy platform and Tower gang being
our more comedy deranged lunatic Outlet
we knew we weren't long for YouTube so
we had to find a platform that would
take care of us in terms of just
allowing us to you know say insane humor
wherever it leads us and gas digital is
uncensored so gasdigitalnetwork.com yep
you got it so you know thinking about
the daily wire for instance because
they've signed a whole bunch of people
you know they keep adding new new Talent
my my view when I look at this stuff is
I I maybe it's just me I personally
cannot relate to the to the desire holy
to sign a deal with another company and
have them take every over to be fair I
completely you know understand the
thought of like man imagine if you could
make this amount of money and then you
didn't have to think about any of the
business and stuff and you can just do
your show and then mind your own
business but I've been down that you
know that rabbit hole I know where that
goes well it's it's that but it's also
the success and the resources that you
now have at your disposal that so few
creators have you know especially if
you're starting out early on you're
trying to make ends meet so if you have
a network that comes to you and they say
I see Talent here I'm going to guarantee
you a living wage as Bernie Sanders
might say they're going to jump at it
you know what's really funny is that
seeing this story from Crowder this is
the identical story to the record label
stories I was 30 years I was just
thinking that yeah but I also kind of uh
see it as a I think as a Benjamin
Franklin quote where he says uh don't
trade uh Liberty for uh security you'll
get neither this is kind of what's going
on here I mean we did it with covid they
we do it all the time there's result
there there are people who only want to
make music and they're never going to
monetize that music and you got to find
somebody who can but you know I think my
view of this whole thing is like dude if
your personality
of any size hire a manager like and I'm
talking about an employee who works for
you and they do what you tell them to do
or they're fired don't sign a contract
with another guy that makes you the
employee yeah the only reason I consider
guests is because you know as I've
already explained I am financially free
I didn't need to go that route but I
don't want to create a network and a
platform that allows for decensored D or
uncensored conversation
um that's just it's such a huge swing
also his network is filled with the most
hardcore insane comics on Earth I wanted
to be in that world because I'm not a
comedian so it just it made a perfect
perfect fit for us but at the end of the
day you're absolutely right if you can
if you have the willpower and the and
the work ethic it will benefit and
behoove you to go that route thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only show goes
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time